there probably hasn't been a bigger or
more dynamic year in recent television
history than 2018 among all this great
TV certain moments proved unforgettable
in ways that for better or worse spans
will be discussing for years here are
the biggest TV moments of 2018 the good
and the bad Henry Winkler has been a TV
legend for more than 40 years in the
1970s he was probably the most popular
cultural figure in America for his work
on Happy Days portraying leather-wearing
jukebox macking ladies man Arthur
Fonzarelli aka Fonzie he received his
first of six Emmy nominations way back
in 1976 for that role but it took until
2018 for Winkler widely regarded as one
of the nicest guys in Hollywood to
finally take home that prized statue for
television excellence for his role is
acting coach Gene kusa now on HBO's dark
comedy Barrie Winkler won the first
trophy of the night at the 2018 Emmy
Awards and the audience left to their
feet as the former Fonzie delivered the
speech he'd written in 1976 the best
part telling his kids who are full grown
adults that it was past their bedtimes
if you've been anywhere even close to
the Internet the past few months then
you know that prolific comic-book writer
and editor Stan Lee whose cameos in
nearly every Marvel movie made him a
familiar figure to billions of people
across the world passed away in November
I guess one person
nuff said with the news that the
co-creator of the Marvel Universe had
died accolades praise and tributes came
pouring in from people in all walks of
life and then real time host Bill Maher
weighed in with a piece on his show's
blog called adulting a disrespectful
dismissal of comics in general and by
extension Lee in particular claiming
that Lee had only ever inspired his fans
to go watch a movie I guess Marv who has
never shied away from using snide
comments to get attention advised comic
book fans to grow up and move on to
big-boy books without the pictures
presumably he meant his books which are
all about how smart Bill Maher is for
knowing about sarcasm Maher dealt with
the fallout of his remarks on who lose
Larry King now he didn't apologize
claiming that he wasn't even aware he'd
caused the hubbub and clarified that he
meant that thinking comic books and
superhero movies could have artistic
Worth was just the symptom of a stupid
culture not a good look especially given
the circumstances
Donald Glover's first time hosting
Saturday Night Live in may 2000 18 was
timed to promote his role as young Lando
and solo a Star Wars story unfortunately
between Atlanta this is America and
absolutely killing it on NBC's
late-night institution that movie might
be the least memorable thing Glover did
all year
Glover shined in every single sketch he
was a part of he played a sleazy lawyer
defending jurassic world over the many
violent dinosaur related deaths for
which it was certainly liable he did
musical comedy and a high concept
sketches raspberry a scorned man who
steps out of an 80s music video to exact
revenge on who he very wrongly thinks as
a cheating girlfriend Glover also served
as the musical guest under his stage
name childish gambino
launching the single that turned out to
be one of the most controversial songs
of the year more than a hundred million
people tuned in to watch the Super Bowl
every year making the halftime show one
of the most criticized and scrutinized
performances of the year if only because
of the sheer magnitude of the gig
without many eyes musicians need to
bring their a-game and when Justin
Timberlake headlined the spectacle for
the first time since the infamous 2004
performance with Janet Jackson he
certainly did that assuming the a stands
for awful while dressed in a camouflage
outfit and a red bandana that made him
look like
Golden Retriever Timberlake pushed his
way through a medley of hits like rock
your body and sexy back he had
reportedly planned to employ a prince
hologram in his set but cancelled it
after objections from among others
Prince himself who once remarked that a
technological recreation of a dead
musician would be the most demonic thing
imaginable
instead he delivered a lackluster cover
of I would die for you alongside an
image of Minnesota's fine is projected
onto a sheet it only served as a
reminder of the controversy
not to mention inviting a comparison to
prince's own for our superior halftime
show in the 2007 Superbowl death is a
major part of the walking dead and every
season brings at least one hard-hitting
tragedy his fan favorite characters
struggle against endless hordes of
zombies in 2018 the show gave us one of
its most excruciating yet
heartbreakingly beautiful deaths when it
killed off Carl Grimes a character who'd
been with the show from the beginning
and who represented hope for the future
Carl had already endured plenty of
tragedies including the death of his
mother while giving birth and the
violent loss of his right eye but
remains strong confident and brave in
the end though Carl was bitten and chose
to end his life in a way that revealed
his inner decency the good and
heartbreaking news is that he had time
to put his affairs in order
bonding with his little sister Judith
than riding poignant letters to his
loved ones making his death even more
effective while it still has plenty of
fans The Walking Dead gradually shed
millions of viewers who were tired of
being manipulated by narrative stunts
season-ending cliffhanger 'he's fake-out
character deaths and killing off fan
favorite characters and a parade of
misery simply war viewers out in late
2018 The Walking Dead once again messed
with fans earlier in the year star
Andrew Lincoln announced that he was
leaving the show AMC heavily promoted
the last episodes featuring Lincoln as
Rick Grimes and most viewers assumed he
died it certainly looked that way when
he blew up a bridge to kill some zombies
and got impaled on metal only to be
airlifted to safety right after this
episode aired AMC announced that Lincoln
would go on to star in three new movies
about Rick meaning that all that fuss
wasn't for a send-off it was just a
promotion for a spinoff instead
it's strange and uncomfortable to
consider a world without adventure time
Pendleton Ward's wildly imaginative
funny tragic and strange Cartoon Network
series changed the game for TV animation
upon its debut back in 2010 over nearly
300 episodes it created an elaborate
land called ooh that was slowly revealed
to be a post-apocalyptic world that had
been nearly destroyed by the great
mushroom war so named for the mushroom
clouds left by nuclear weapons in the
1-hour final episode the great gum war
ends not with the horrific violence of
the great mushroom war which led to the
land of ooze formation but with peace as
the leaders of the two factions agree to
rule in tandem
but then glob the most evil thing in
existence sees that calm as an opening
to return and does all kinds of awful
things in the end goodness wins out and
viewers see [ __ ] becoming the future
ruler abou [ __ ] tells the story of the
war to two young adventurers named sure
me and Beth who bear a striking
resemblance to Finn and Jake it was a
thrilling if bittersweet finish to a
show that already ranks among modern
animated classics reboots were huge in
2018 including the reboot at the 2000s
pop-culture sensation Queer Eye for the
straight guy both then and now the show
sends five gay identifying lifestyle
experts to help slobbing Lee hetero
dudes clean up their acts and better
their lives the 2018 version turned down
the camp and turned up the emotion as a
brand new fab 5 based in Atlanta helped
individuals improve more than just their
wardrobes making connections across race
religion and economic status
demonstrating that healing was possible
in a divided culture but one moment rang
totally flats reminding viewers that
this particular reality show is very
real on the third episode of the queer
eye reboot the gang piles into a car to
go help out at Georgia man named Corey
before they get there a cop pulls them
over cast member caramel Brown an
african-american man is behind the wheel
and viewers can see his face fall flat
as he faces a situation with the
potential to get tense at best
the officer sternly approaches the
vehicle and asks Brown to get out which
Browns co-stars firmly protested but hey
don't worry it's all a joke this cop is
just Henry the guy who nominated his
friend and someone who really
understand that making marginalized
people feel threatened isn't all that
funny
the only good part of the show was that
Kurama was able to discuss his fear in a
way that was accessible to both the
audience and to Cory a conversation that
brought a whole lot of depth to a show
that's usually focused on how to tuck in
your shirt